well I might be a I know bad taste but
to no get bad taste you have to have
know all the rules of good taste with my
which my parents painstakingly taught me
that's probably why I rebelled
I was almost fascist Lee good taste I
was raised with but I'm thankful for
actually because you can't have fun with
bad taste unless you know how to break
but you know the rules to break
I actually think I have good taste I
don't think I have bad taste I am I
think fashion can use bad taste
certainly fashion can take the worst
thing that everybody threw out and make
everybody want to spend too much money
and buy it again that's a magic trick
that's art isn't it that's not Edie
chase its brilliance if he has me but
taste is ever-changing and I always tell
kids if you want to change start a
fashion revolution you get on the
fashion nerves of the people that are
three years older than you that are hip
not your parents you have to get the
people that were your age that just just
discovered something and you got to
knock them down from that met from that
I don't know that mantle of fashion
success to start your own so obviously
when you're young thrift shops are the
place to go but I can't find anything in
thrift shops anymore so I spend too much
money on clothes that look like they
were the worst thing in a thrift shop
but if you're young you really can buy
the worst thing in a thrift shop and
look really really fashionable and pull
it off
well certainly without a lot of the
designers I like it does look like
something's wrong with them and I have a
really good cleaner in Baltimore know
those finally learn how to do everything
because the dry cleaning instructions on
some of these clothes are hilarious I
mean you think the onion Rotom I mean
they're but but they're so complicated
said yes fabric may fade rip bleach
become disordered like what he just paid
a thousand dollars but uh it is kind of
great because it's fashion in Reverse
and then I can wear these clothes to
like blue collar bars and Baltimore and
nobody thinks you're bragging no there's
anything but ostentatious they say to me
in Baltimore that's a shame about that
shirt and they don't know that it cost a
thousand dollars it's hilarious I think
it's like same reason Andy Warhol
supposedly sometimes under his GAAP
turtleneck or $100,000 woman's necklace
nobody could see it but but he nearly
had it on it's the same principle it's
not bragging and it's not condescending
to other people and it's not using
fashion to the fashion I'd never wear as
designer names or logos on it or
anything like that that's for the that's
for people that are very insecure about
their fashion taste